elle ce qu'un jour on vous a dit une
phrase du genre prends tes affaires et
rentrer chez toi
benjamin castany ça nous arrivait
souvent voir wissam et à m oui oui
bétail mais savez-vous hashtag prends
tes affaires
ouais ou au moins une fois oui ce qui
s'est passé vous savez j'ai une vie j'ai
été marié deux à quatre fois parce qu'il
paraît que vous avez quitté votre
première femme
deux jours avant le nouvel an ah oui
c'est vrai bah c'est sa liste arrive à 6
oui mais lui il est amnésique mission
dans notre jeu pas amnésiques temps mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que je suis
parti mais c'est moi qui suis partie 1
mais pour ça que vous me posez la
question aux affaires et ne revient pas
c'est moi j'ai pris mes affaires je suis
partie moche de moi même pour ça que ça
merci donc qu'il a quitté sa première
femme deux jours avant le nouvel an et
le 3 janvier il divorce est déjà la
deuxième fois alors benhaim vous moi moi
j'ai dit à quelqu'un tu prends tes
affaires et revient pas non c'est vrai
c'était même si on a eu la gentillesse
de m'envoyer une photo c'est de citer
tout jeune je devrais je pas 24 25 ans
une photo de la personne en soirée en
train d'embrasser une personne qui
n'était pas moi non et il était
peut-être une heure ou deux heures du
matin mais moi comme je suis je dors à
ces moments là moi je si on me dit je
vais sortir jeudi basse très bien sauf
sauf que je m'en suis je m'en suis
rendue le lendemain matin encore me
réveillant j'ai vu une photo et le pire
c'est quand on te dit non mais c'est
parce que tu crois
mais la photo c'est l'anru la société en
plus pour une imbécile alors moi je
déteste ça pour ça on est exactement
dans les privilèges et les photos et les
rappels irréprochable dans le métier oui
et donc va donc du coup j'ai dit prends
tes affaires n'ont rien pu rentrer chez
toi rôles chez toi si tu nous lis
l'avantagent si vous êtes le club de
kelly b novelli ce qu'elle se réveille à
15 heures vous avez tant j'avais le
temps de nettoyer tout ça
ouais gras durs tonte adjani prends tes
affaires entier doit wap la fois les ex
bah oui bon live en doute les videurs de
boîte aussi des videurs de boîte ou très
souvent mais prends tes affaires en
chinois il ya plein de il ya plein de
gens qui t'ont dit protège affaires et
un vaudois jean michel bayet moi georges
était avec une fille depuis assez
longtemps c'est une grande histoire
c'est fait depuis à peu près 6 7 enfin
et pas de bol c'est et tombe amoureux
d'une fille qui travaille avec moi
j'étais à france soir à l'époque et est
du coup elle m'avait mis dans mon
portefeuille pendant la journée sans que
je rende compte vous photo d'elle avec
une déclaration d'amour sur la photo non
portefeuille et le soir gens de chez moi
et c'est irréprochable et ma femme me
demande quelque chose j'y vas prendre
mon portefeuille mais je sais et moi je
pars pour ma douche hall prendre ma
douche et je sors de la douche serviette
autour de blanche et je vais dans le dos
qui arrive dans la chambre où le paca
pour chercher un tee shirt qui joue pas
d'affaires pendant que pris ma douche
avait pris toutes les affaires tout
foutu sur le palier et cloud comme ça il
n'y a plus rien de la vie des affaires
ah oui je suis sorti en peignoir en
serviette sur le cul sur le palier et je
me serais bien sûr travailler je suis
parti et j'ai jamais revenu farce l'a
jamais voulu janvier et vous êtes vous
êtes allés avec l'autre jeune fille de
françois c'est très peu parce qu'elle
était elle c'est une histoire compliquée
aussi et vous 3 janvier 2002
[Rires]
j'ai lu ça faire plus compliqué mais par
des athées rentrer chez toi puisse
analyser la laisser comme abidji
monétaire petite amie c'était ma prof
d'anglais en fait qu elle et voir leur
site à mist et votre prof d'anglais
ouais ouais 27 ans à lormont quel âge et
j'avais 13 ans l argent
il aimait les cours de langue fait c'est
mourir d'aimer l'histoire narrée taille
temps mais je faisais langueur en force
et en plus je t'ai pas bon mais
l'histoire de du président exaltant
présent non 13 ans et 13 ans et un frère
ya peu il n'y a pas eu papa de la preuve
qu'on est très présent mais 13 ans et 2
mois et avait déjà une vraie histoire
d'amour c'est qui c'est une vraie
histoire d'amour c'est une prof
d'anglais cité avait renoncé au lycée
devait renoncer nous regardent fini
parce qu'elle a été débutée but he who
[Rires]
mais non
l'un des buts est invité la france donc
moi je me suis repris ces tests à la fin
de ma première histoire d'amour
bah c'est bon c'est bon kicker sexuelle
qui n'a jamais manqué qu'elle y soit que
la dialyse affronter d'affaires aux
normales oui je les ai déjà dit à
certains hommes oui bah oui c'est tout
et ils sont partis non mais ils sont
partis très bien mais qui s'accroche
d'autres moins la ola chocolat sont pas
nouveaux
autant sur les dossiers autant sur que
non j'ai dit c'est peut-être en ce
moment là c'est vrai je la sens joue à
la maison je pense qu'il ya un bail à un
mec là qu'est en train de faire ses
affaires
josé luis josé louis dans les salles je
vais lui dans les salles ya un dossier
avec josé luis avec kylie on peut pas en
dire plus sachez ça et pas mathieu
s'alarmer mais je te rends compte
et depuis ce jour là je ne suis pas tout
seul il a été ainsi que je n'avais pas
chez honda pas chez toi en principe
arabe donne aux autres hommes ne jamais
habité chez l'autre voilà et moi ce jour
là je ne savais pas depuis j'habite
toujours chez moi à l'époque j'habitais
chez là où j'habitais chez moi j'habite
chez moi oui moi je paye je peux y avait
pas deux prévenus me rappelle
parce que j'oblige devient gravure il
habite chez moi voilà voilà voilà
et donc voilà je vous dirai pas
confiance et catherine durand la mer
c'est un monsieur de leur mauvais
obligea quittance du monde adore oui
vous ne rêvez un petit prix d'indy quand
même pour le loyer non non on va
regarder le marché
on se dit bah voilà ça fait ça à prix
d'ami alors ça commence à rentrer dans
des années non non vous avez fait un
état des lieux avant après oui même si
la personne est rapidement et donc ce
jour-là on s'engueule je m'énerve et je
dis [ __ ] prends tes affaires et 4 3
mais deuxième était chez moi en indycar
bangladesh et pour moi c'est une réponse
à madonna tu étais au nutella est pareil
quand on sert de malone a objecté like a
bird jeunes arabes et les mets mon chéri
mais non et du coup bah je prends mes
affaires j'ai mes petites voitures de
sport très jeune à l'époque je tâte la
voiture de sport et oms est passée la
première où je suis allé chez moi chez
lui chez lui dans les rangs les sulley à
castanet
ma chambre est à côté de celle d'enzo
son fils qui était mignon c'est pas bien
mais la croque stand hall à l'époque il
est resté trop septembre c'était il ya
huit ans mais preuve cette année chez
castaldi gentiment un soir il fallait
pas me dire deux fois et je connais il y
avait personne atteint que je connais
c'est qu'elle est assez de paugnat pour
m'engager à l'époque où castagnettes et
valérie et il était drôle parce qu'à
l'époque et j'ai toujours dit petacchi
bucci lui étourdi potes qui étaient là
on joue aux cartes ont maté la télé donc
sur le port du compte je suis rentré
dans la partie et horriblement vulgaire
y avait une baignoire avec des néons de
fait gro jacuzzi aux baignoires
il avait tué la baignoire où il avait
fait la part tout ça est donc je
disparaissais de trois jours comme ça et
puis en fait vous savez ce qui lui
arrive de châtas pas non que les néons
un peu mégalo je me sens que par terre
il y avait sur le carrelage avait été
initié mais c'est vrai carnage sur le
mécénat et plus loin la vpc déjà le
baisser poursuit il il avait fait un
hammam un sauna mène depuis
l'appartement
il est marqué sur les mosaïques en bas
comme ça il est marqué benjamin vous
croyez seulement
[Rires]
oui mais c'est au tour de max et pas
bertrand choqué dans sa baignoire mais
sa beauté le début de la phrase mais
c'est votre froc
c'est con parce qu'on s'amuse à nous
mais moi je vais toujours mes initiales
sur les robinets
oui il est resté quand même six mois
chez moi à 3 36 mois et un amour il y
avait certaines voitures et tout net je
prends m les voitures par les week-ends
et bill
mais même ces femmes les mettent marron
le remerciait ce que tu lui as
maintenant quand on fait un choix
ravitaillement non non non on s'amusait
ce que nous devons faire de la bouffe un
jour j'en mettrais à l'est puis en
battant lé conducteur reste on vous a
offert un cadeau pour vous mais alors il
mal fait il m'a fait un seul cadeau il
m'a jamais invité au restaurant on n'y
paraissait un plein de courses ni rien
il m'a fait un cadeau du parti à mon
avis c'est un cadeau qu'on l'avait fait
à lui et avec une enveloppe avec un bon
pour un week-end pour deux personnes en
normandie
non non non non dits à la ferme
saint-siméon ou sur les macro permet
d'écouter une tonne n'était pas un bon
j'avais cassé ma tirelire ce papa marié
deschamps pareil tu sais qu'elle va la
faire les saint siméon laon fleurs et
des salles sont des voitures vendues
connaissez avocado bah oui mais j'ai une
question
maintenant que tu es plus riche que lui
est ce que tu fais l'hébergeur est ce
que tu l'adresse non non non non mais
faut d'abord d'attirer vu que c'est
ciani qui héberge
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai prévu une dernière chose avec
vous oui quand j'ai pris la porte en
septembre pardon c'est vraiment entre
nous la petite pièce que dans la
deuxième chambre mais dit ce sera une
buanderie très rapidement et les travaux
vont être faits oui bon ça fait huit
mois n'y a pas eu de travaux je me suis
renseigné que la propre copropriété vous
avez fait une demande pour acheter la
pièce que vous n'est toujours pas acheté
d'ailleurs elle ne vous appartient pas
mais ces prix j'ai une machine de dans
la moi j'ai mes machines à laver nasa
vous appartient pas sa buanderie écoutez
je suis en train de régler ça laissez la
justice faire son travail
bah moi je fais un truc à vous l'achète
lequel paraît que vous allez partir vous
allez partir on va être vraiment prêts à
10 mai mais pas du même nom ben on doit
les uns c'est pas une prison j'ai besoin
de demander au propriétaire quand même à
dire l'âge de la maladie mais s'est
comporté quand vous verrez je donnais
mon président je donne mon avis ça vous
semaine à recommander ou encore des
sacoches et housses si au niveau des
départs toi je vais faire l'état des
lieux
elle consomme
gosu pas une caution d y ait pas de
caution journées passent et la tension
n'ait pas pris de coup ce n'est pas
prise avant inquiétez pas je voulais
vrai la source la ville va nous faire
tout le soir tout le restant de l'année
gratuitement bonsoir bonsoir savourer ce
qu'on vous a dit prends ton baluchon et
bartok
non non non non mais j'avais déjà
commencé à vous raconter l'histoire non
non non on me l'a jamais dit parce que
je m'en fous en plus donc voilà ça c'est
pas pour votre mariage était sur un
bateau une barque un jour avec une barre
quoi bateau c'est bien là franchement
moi non mais souplesse et une barrière
tu fais pas ça toi énormément région et
aux gt sur la barre qui me mène en
bateau si j'ose dire
et puis il avait appris que j'avais
écrit un mot gentil à un homme qui me
courtisait parce que jouer sur les deux
j'essayais de jouer sur les deux
tableaux et il m'a dit tu sais moi j'ai
appris et là dessus mais dit tu détestes
contre nous la tête et ma peau fille tu
vas devoir te mouiller et là il a sauté
à l'eau avec les rames et j'ai dû moi
mais juste et dans la flotte pour gagner
là alors évidemment j'étais entièrement
mouillé et voilà la seule fois où j'ai
dû me mouiller véritablement les chérit
le calvaire est finie c'est plus calme
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est plus qu'un mort est sonné et là on
continue on peut pas enchaîner sur les
anecdotes mamie et maxime génie
[Rires]
là les mecs là franchement dans la tête
les super anecdotes et moi bien dégoûté
bonne sur la tête de ma mère je me mets
tous à poil et je vais me jeter contre
une voiture
les créatures se moqueront car ils
scalpent les nazis alors les balles et
préparer les voitures vers la fin on
croit crois quoi une belle histoire
c'est bon mais on est en 2010 à huawei
ah oui quoi il ya quelques années à
peine une copine szavay 2 2 mois elle
part en vacances avec moi de ma famille
en charente-maritime dans quelques jours
simplement est là et elle se met à se
bourrer les donc 5 thomas se bronzer
mais elle se brosser les dents avec
n'importe qui avec mon frère qui se
brossent également aidant elle s'est
mise à se brosser les dents et à se
rapprocher des vêtements de mon frère en
évoluant demain le lendemain je ne lui
ai pas demandé ni de prendre son
baluchon est parti et martine
d'elle-même à et ça a pris et moi avec
mon frère sera marquée où le relais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
x notamment pour vous savez plus quoi
faire de votre aide a poireauté de leurs
mots s'il vous plaît je chante maritime
ça danse ça va me suis endormi à maxime
[Rires]
ya l'autre derrière et elle sur tech ton
frère m'a prévenue et ensuite laissé un
jumeau non non pas du toit à de la
tendance je m'ouvre change pas grand
chose sinon il n'aurait pas l'air
pressés de se taper le ferait rigoler
même vous avez joué vous ouais nan c'est
moyen même gaffe à toi pas jumeaux
absolument je suis un jumeau barrette
frérot tard à l'eau mais malheureusement
il est payé
[Rires]